all right you ready to use a different
part of your brain sure yeah how do you
get to that other part do you have to is
there some keys what do you get to me I
just thought you know it might not show
up it might be the same I might just
start talking about Islam again okay
well let's let's see if we can do this
without Islam but I think we can't I
have a good friend so I I told you that
I listen to the audiobook of freewill
again yesterday by the way I don't know
if you saw my tweet but the picture
that's supposed to be you is someone
else did you see that oh they came
through your car yeah yeah that's
happened to me do you know who that guy
is
yeah yeah sam harris the original sam
harris who the only sam harris had ever
heard of before is that the musician sam
harris you now he was a Star Search
singer who then became an actor yeah
he's been reasonably successful on stage
and he's been in some thick he was in a
sitcom yeah but he's a little older than
me and someone who I were on got in
touch with and said listen some
controversial material is going to be
coming out under your name right you
know you might not want to go to any
mosques or and so he and I we've never
met but we've communicated by email and
yeah he's aware of me and probably not
so happy that and with all your Zionist
funding in connections you couldn't get
your picture swapped out right that I
don't know what happens I buy all of
those pictures almost never right yeah I
don't know I think anyway that's not the
point of this so I listen to free will
again yesterday and but I thought of
just a funny point there's my first
editor once when I was writing the end
of faith for some brief period of time
got confused and thought I actually was
that Sam Harris and I was that was
actually quite dismayed to know that
that in addition to all this other stuff
I was claiming to be doing I was singing
show tunes and wow that would end
something yeah is that that could be the
next version of Sam is this Sam hat once
you saw the Islam that would require a
deep neurosurgery and yeah complex that
way you have the right possible yeah all
right so I listened to it again
yesterday and I want you to lay I just
want you to lay out the one little bit
you don't have to give me the whole
audio book again but first just sort of
the difference between
you're feeling on it and Daniel Dennett
because when I was listening to it I
felt at least for the first half where
you guys were where you were discussing
this and your sort of difference I
really wanted to agree with him I felt
that despite the case that you laid out
I wanted that I'd sit here with you and
I'd go well if I don't have free will or
if it's so stuck back in my cosmic thing
then why what's stopping me from picking
up this book and whacking you in the
head with it
now you lay out a claim why I wouldn't
actually be making that conscious
decision sort of so did I did I frame
that basically right well it it you've
actually driven to the hardest question
to answer which is which I actually
don't have a great answer which is what
exactly is the difference between my
view and Dan's yeah so Dan Dennett for
those who don't know as a philosopher
who's written multiple books on the
topic of free will he's a very famous
philosopher of mind and also a friend
and colleague of mine on the front who
mostly on the front between science and
religion but so one of the new atheists
and four horsemen and it was and he I've
collaborated in that way we don't we
disagree about a lot in the philosophy
of mind and we disagreed very visibly on
the topic of free will but I think we
have been talking past one another a
fair amount we just did a podcast a two
podcast back on my podcast where we
talked about this and it's still even
there wasn't totally clear to me what
the difference is maybe it's largely a
matter of emphasis it's largely a matter
of Dan thinking that this almost goes
back to what we were talking about
earlier about certain ideas being either
dangerous or socially counterproductive
to to advertise and so he thinks that
the idea of free will the idea that
people that most people have is
important enough ethically and as a
matter of jurisprudence and a matter of
just just how the smooth functioning of
individuals in a society that we
shouldn't disavow it in the way that I
do in my book and that is born not of a
deep difference with me about the
science or the underlying philosophy but
he just thinks this is is essentially
you need to want to throw the baby out
with a bathwater argument with respect
to the concept of free will now I think
actually the concept is is bad enough
and comes with enough of its entangled
problems that getting rid of the concept
actually does good things rather than
bad things and so I think we differ on
that a little bit but again it's not
totally clear but just to get people up
to speed here most people are walking
around with a sense that of what
philosophers call libertarian free will
is the sense that that what you think
and do what you've what you intend and
what and what then becomes your most
deliberate voluntary action is something
that you as an agent or authoring and
that you really are responsible for this
authorship that you are there's no one
upstream who is you know pulling the
marionette strings and therefore you are
morally culpable for the bad things you
do intentionally and and you know with
with planning etc so as you say in the
book so that you for example that you
make a conscious decision on this
morning to have coffee instead of tea
right there's nothing pre-written
that's a that's sort of pushing you one
way or another but these but that what
they would say is that you are making
these decisions in the moment for
whatever reasons you're making them
there yeah and it is but but the the
Devils in the details of what you mean
by you so so so for to give Dan his his
due here dan thinks that you is not just
your conscious awareness of yourself
it's not who you
yourself to be subjectively it's the
totality of your person it's your it's
all the neural activity in your brain
that you're not aware of but it's still
you because in your body right so and so
there's there's a kind of a first-person
way of talking about you which is your
your sense of yourself your subjectivity
and there's a third-person way of
talking about you which is from the
outside just your your body your genome
your your you as a as a person and those
don't totally map on to each other
because what you're conscious of as a as
a subject is not the totality of what's
going on in your body you're certainly
not conscious of the your genes
transcribing proteins and you're not
conscious of most of the neural activity
going on in your brain right so so
what's your and yet what's your
conscious of includes for most people
it's felt sense that you are the thinker
of your thoughts and the initiator of
your actions and you are an agent your
subject in consciousness as opposed to
just the kind of a space in which things
are happening right and so I'm going to
put a few things to the side no one's
disputing I'm not disputing and Dan
wouldn't dispute we agree a bit that
there's a there are important
differences between voluntary and
involuntary action and you know there
are people who have neurological
illnesses and impairments that that give
them less degrees of freedom and the
people who you know are our phobic of
certain things or they have
obsessive-compulsive disorder or they're
you know you're blind or they're things
that that that can reduce your capacity
to act quote freely in the world and
those reductions matter right and if
you're in prison and you're being
coerced to to write a confession well
that's different from actually
confessing me all these differences or
matter and no one's disputing any of
that but the issue for me is that people
have a a sense
that what they take that what they
experience themselves to be as low sigh
of consciousness and it's just that they
come to you in your head that it that
can look at a glass of water and say oh
I'd like to drink that and then reach
that there's the feeling that that free
will describes a freedom there which
runs very very deep which means to say
that if you could rewind the movie of
your life to a one-minute ago hmm the
last question you asked might come out
differently you might have asked a
different question right we finished the
sentence differently right
and so you know that the moment where I
decide to reach for this glass it's
coming now
but if you could return my brain and the
universe to the state it was in a few
moments ago it might it might not have
happened right now there is no
scientific or philosophical reason to
believe that right so if everything we
know about just how causes propagate in
the universe were they talking about
physics out there you're talking about
the the neurophysiology in here or even
if you're talking about the influence of
some immaterial soul that we - you might
think exists right in whatever a
concatenation of causes you think caused
you to think and do the next thing you
think and do all of that is just
happening and if you set all of those
causes back to where they were at the
moment ago it's going to happen a
trillion times in a row in the same way
right so so basically the primordial
stew sort of that led you to being you
is what you're saying doesn't give us
free will sort of in the way that he
says it right he's saying it because of
their societal reasons we need to say it
well he's saying there's a pragmatic way
of construing freewill yeah
which still MB that emphasizes the
difference between someone who does
something intentionally of his own free
will because he wanted to do it and
someone who does something by accident
or because he's got a brain tumor and
those two those people are different and
we can lock this one away and throw it
and throw away the key and these people
we can rehabilitate two
or feel sorry for and those differences
get conserved even though we know this
person that both of them both sides are
essentially robots they couldn't do
otherwise right right uh but my argument
is it's not that simple and actually
some very good things happen when you
notice that even the most seemingly
culpable person ever I mean just my
favorite example someone like Saddam
Hussein or his sons and he's like the
least sympathetic person the person
who's not it's not like there's
something neurologically wrong with him
he is just a sadistic bastard who wants
to harm people and is getting away with
it for years at a stretch and it's
totally unrepentant then when you
capture him you think aha I finally have
the bad guy who we can hang or we can be
put in prison forever and and it's it's
the punishment is justified not merely
because we're keeping people safe by
taking him off the streets it's
justified because he really deserves it
right he's really he's the author of his
evil right now that final move of
viewing people as the authors of
themselves right I think is
scientifically and ethically
illegitimate and and so what the things
what you get from my point of view when
you lose this commitment to free will is
you you undercut any rational basis for
hating people hatred doesn't make any
sense vengeance in in the usual sense
doesn't make any sense
now you can fear people yeah you because
you know they're dangerous you can lock
them up forever if you can't cure their
their evil and you would do that to wild
animals and hurricanes and anything else
you fear that if you could lock up
hurricanes you'd lock up hurricanes but
you wouldn't tribute freewill to them so
there's still problems in the world in
the world that have to be solved and
some only can be solved with force at
the moment but the the vengeful
righteous retributive justice module
gets completely silenced by this insight
and the insight is just obvious because
no one picked their parents right no
therefore no one picked their genomes no
one picked this
into which they were born no one picked
any of the environmental influences that
played upon their genes so as to produce
precisely the person they are so there's
not a cell in your body that you chose
and yet every cell in your body is
expressing itself as the person that you
are and even if you added an immortal
soul to that clockwork you didn't pick
your soul and you didn't you're not
responsible for the fact that you
weren't given a soul of a psychopath and
some people were given the soul of a
psychopath and now they are helplessly
being psychopaths and I mean that the
common starting point for philosophers
for thousands of years the reason why it
seemed like we haven't made any progress
on this issue is and why this has seemed
like such a durable problem for
philosophy is people have sensed that
there really is a mystery here there's
this subjective fact about us that we
experience ourselves as free agents as
the true authors of our thoughts and
actions but you can't square it with the
world of causes because well however you
talk about determinism or randomness or
some combination thereof that doesn't
seem to give you any basis for freedom
but what I do in the book and what I
what I do I mean what I'm doing now is
argue that actually the subjective side
is an illusion we don't actually have
this experience free will and so I mean
the it's not that free will really is an
illusion merely the illusion is an
illusion if you look closely at the
illusion isn't it you realize it wasn't
even there in the first place and and
this is in the you sort of have to know
how to meditate to really take this
deeply but most people can Intuit this
if if they just are led to look at their
inner lives a little more closely than
normal so if I ask you I don't think I
run this experiment the book but I've
done it with some audiences but if I
asked you to think of a famous person
right now just think of somebody famous
mm-hmm and those let's do this a few
times just so you can be sensitive to
the process and now forget that famous
person just think of a totally different
famous person pick him or her mm-hmm and
do it do it do it one more time but just
pay attention to what the experience is
like of picking a new famous person
so you have somebody mm-hmm okay so now
on either of those trials did you think
of Sylvester Stallone no right okay so
you know Sylvester Stallone is a famous
person right so like I say Sylvester
Stallone you Britney just that's a
perfectly good candidate for being a
famous person right mm-hmm
now so the first thing to point out is
so so here if we can't find freedom of
will here it's nowhere I mean this is as
free as it gets right me it's just you
with your thoughts you can take it you
can take as long as you want you could
have taken an hour to think of a famous
person you could have gone to the
inventory of famous people and and
picked one but let's look let's find
freedom here right because this is you
just picking without without any
coercion which famous person of all the
famous names you know what you're going
to focus on well first of all they're
all the famous people who you just don't
happen to know about right so you
couldn't pick them they'll freedom there
because that their names couldn't have
occurred to you you know famous you know
Norwegian actresses right you may know
none of them right as opened and so
there's no freedom there so then there's
the set of famous people who you know
who could have possibly occurred to you
now Sylvester Stallone you know probably
as well as anyone right and and yet he
didn't occur to you what does it mean to
say that you were free to pick him now
you were free in the sense that no one
was standing at your head with a gun
saying listen if you pick Sylvester
Stallone we're going to kill you so
don't like him right but what does it
mean in what sense were you free to pick
someone who didn't occur to you to pick
mm-hmm now I would say as a matter of
neurophysiology that's a completely
empty statement and it's the early years
of Sylvester Stallone circuits we're
just not active right but for whatever
reason a reason you didn't pick right a
reason what you to which you don't stand
as author now absolutely everything in
your life is like that everything no
matter no matter how deliberate of the
decision the person you choose to
arrey whether you do whether you decide
to get married or just live together
whether you want water or versus tea
well it's you can make it as as a
long-term or a short-term as you want
there there's in the in the in the
darkness of your unconscious mind all of
which is preceded and it can be borne
forward by your your genes and your and
the life circumstance and all of the
ideas that get in or don't get in the
conversations you have and don't have
this full concatenation of causes and
you could add a dose of randomness to
that and you could add some magic from
from the soul realm to whatever is there
right you just have it
various thought thoughts and intentions
springing into view and you can't you
you can't you don't choose them
you can't think a thought before you
think it right I'm so you to choose your
thoughts you'd have to thank them before
you thought them I mean they just spring
into view right so very much like the
names of famous people so you didn't
know I was going to ask you to think of
a famous person right I ask you now all
of a sudden you've got the various names
percolating mm-hmm one of which was not
Sylvester Stallone but could have been
right now so so if you had thought of
Sylvester Stallone that wouldn't have
astonished you it's like you it just
would have been okay so faster slow and
Marlon Brando yeah you would have just
been thinking right it would just have
been another name but then I would have
said well why didn't you think of Chris
Rock he said I don't know I didn't think
of Cory why he's just as familiar to you
and yet he didn't come forward well it's
exactly like that with everything and it
doesn't get you don't get any freer the
more the more you deliberate like if I
said listen don't rush this project I
want you to take an hour right you know
you'd be the same process and let's say
you narrow it down to two people and
you're going back and forth between
Marlon Brando and Chris Rock and then
you you finally stick with Brando now
whatever story you have to tell yourself
that justifies that you didn't pick that
either right did you dig that story you
didn't pick the story uh and I mean in
many cases those stories aren't even
true
like that we there's a vast
psychological literature on just how
clueless people are about why they do
what they do in certain circumstances
and you can manipulate this in the lab
endlessly but even if the story is true
right even if you say whoa I picked
marlon brando because i saw that
documentary on him last week and it was
great and you should see it and as I was
kind of primed to think about Marlon
Brando let's say that's just true right
still you didn't pick its influence on
you right like why were you influenced
to that degree and not a lesser degree
or why weren't you influenced oppositely
why didn't why didn't the fact that you
had seen a documentary on him make you
think well I just can't take Brando
because you know I've been thinking
about him all week long I'm gonna go
with Chris Rock right all of this is
mysterious all its it's just it never
becomes unmistakable or genome and and
you're neurophysiology and all of its
influences over which you have
absolutely no control and every moment
where you decide to assert control it's
like let's say you're just you you feel
like you're not have discipline in your
life you think you wake up tomorrow
morning you think you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna start working out I'm
going to cut off sugar out of my diet
I'm going to really get a handle on all
these problems right where does that
come from
that's just like it's Sylvester Stallone
just for the it'll always pull the rug
out from under you in a way it's all
it's always coming out of the darkness
yeah it's it and every I can't like
listen to me say the sentence I don't
know how I'm going to get to the end of
the sentence right there are times where
I failed to get to the end of the sense
I don't speak grammatically correctly
right right but the successfully
completing a sentence is as mysterious
as anything else like how do you how do
you follow the rules of grammar when you
speak I don't do it that well often but
it I might it's it's a miracle that you
do it at all right right but in the same
thing it's like this is this is as
intentional in action as you're ever
going to find like I'm choosing to move
my hand well how do I do it
right if you move your hand it is
subjectively and again it doesn't matter
how much you know about the process in
third-person terms you can know about
you know muscle fibers and action
potentials and know the names of every
neurotransmitter involved and you could
just have it you could write a book
about what is actually going on when you
move your hand and you could be the
person competent to write that book and
you could still as a matter of your
first-person subjectivity have no idea
how you accomplish this and if you
suddenly couldn't write if you were
suddenly paralyzed that would be as
mysterious as well it would just be
either this thing that you were taking
for granted you know albeit for reasons
that are totally mysterious suddenly
stops yeah right and so that is a so my
argument is that we don't actually
experience the freewill we think we
experience we don't experience ourselves
being the true authors of our desires
and our intent intentions and our
thoughts and these things that lead to
actions but we actually experience
ourselves as part of the universe I mean
we're being we are forces of nature we
are being played our strings are being
pulled by the universe so to bring this
back to where we started so if I picked
up this book right now and whacked you
in the head with it you don't deny that
I'm making the choice to do that but
basically you're saying it is all of the
history of everything in my brain and
every and my parents and all the things
that went on before me was me sort of
that will have given me a sort of
framework to decide to do that or not
but I don't really even understand that
well what I mean one person because I'm
making the choice not to hit you in yeah
I could try just say yeah we can really
see if this works well it does I mean
this this is what people are worried
about there is a difference between
doing it intentionally and not and that
difference is still conserved because
I'm it's just unpack what this means if
one intentionally hits you as opposed to
hitting you by accident right that says
much more about their minds I mean be an
intentional action is associated with
intention is associated with it's the
kind of thing that you you kind of
modeled in your mind before you did it
right and you picked your moment and
then you did it and these tend to be the
kinds of things that you wanted to do
you had some goal associated with doing
it right you you would do it again if
given the chance right so like the
person who physically harms you on
purpose as opposed to the person who
just didn't see you were there and just
backed into you right that person it is
actually an expression of ill-will right
and that's all of those differences
matter does that mean that that's its
predictive of what that person is going
to be like in the next moment yeah and
and so it all that matters for for you
know criminal trials and everything else
but the the difference is that when you
see that people aren't really really
deep deep down responsible for who they
are you know the psychopath isn't is on
some level unlucky to be a psychopath
you know if I if I had the brain of a
psychopath I would be a psychopath Yeah
right and through no fault fault of my
own really it then undermines a basis
for hating these people you can actually
feel genuinely sorry for people who also
scare you who also if given know others
but redress you would you know kill in
self-defense right because you know you
there's just no no you know no
alternative or you'll lock them up for
the rest of their lives because you have
to keep other people safe from them but
the retributive story of they really
deserve it because they're evil and
they're responsible for it that goes
away and that you know good riddance to
that I don't see anything very freeing
ultimately oh yeah and when I can
remember this way of thinking dealing
with people like Glenn Greenwald it
actually helps perfect segue to this
because I told you before I read it I
took eight days off or 9 days off I
locked my phone in a safe I did not even
have the code to the safe no tweeting no
emailing no nothing and I was on a beach
that my view basically looked like the
cover of the book which was pretty nice
and I read this and you've described a
lot of things you've just described
while talking about free will are sort
of directly related to this in terms of
the way we think and sort of being
unable to control what the next thought
is or even why we have that next thought
and all that stuff so before we get into
that though can you just tell me a
little bit about where did this desire
come from in you in the book you kind of
talk about doing some drugs when you
were younger and traveling a bit and
you've studied with all kinds of shamans
and people all over the world and all
this but we're I mean when you were 12
were you into this sort of existential
stuff or that it's Mark later or was it
the drugs or what well actually it did
start pretty early I had a best friend
who died when I was 13 and so thoughts
about death and just what it all means
happened pretty early for me so it's
that my teenage years were years where I
was seeking to understand you know
religion and and all the rest and all
has started pretty early but it wasn't
until I think I was 18 and did MDMA
which I start the book with an account
of my first MBA trip and that really was
the kind of psychological breakthrough
for me because it was not of all this
was before MDMA was the rave drug or
whatever would you just take it at a
party and never really think that your I
mean no doubt I'm not discounting the
the positive experiences people have in
that context but when I took it it was
very much with the purpose of
discovering something about my mind you
know and so I was just with a single
friend and we just this this drug had
been advertised to us as something that
could really reveal something about just
the the nature of the human mind and the
possibility for feeling a kind of
well-being that we were not tending to
feel and that's exactly what we
experienced and it was very you
for those who've taken MDMA is won't be
a surprise but major drugs are again
it's also a kind of suitcase term that
isn't very useful drugs it is like it's
a word like religion where the it names
vastly different quantities and
spectrums of effects and so MDMA is not
at all like LSD or any other drew any
other drug which it's usually
categorized with there was no
psychedelic component you know no change
in visual properties or anything what
there was was just a feeling of just a
drop in a way of self concern that was
totally liberating and I just I never
realized that I was carrying around this
burden of self mm-hmm
to the degree that I was and you know
when talking to somebody that part of my
attention was bound up in worrying about
what they thought of me right like I
wasn't just seeing the other person I
was sir triangulating on myself through
their eyes and if I said something that
that seemed your I was like we were
looking at their face seeing the
reaction that I was getting and a good
one meant something and a bad one meant
something all this was being played back
into me and modifying how I felt about
myself and and so I so I was sitting
with it with a very close friend at the
time and it was just it just a dropping
away of this or even like I just say I I
think it didn't he didn't even notice it
drop away at the moment but just kind of
retrospectively realized oh my god this
thing is gone right this this this
monster of me yeah which has been behind
my face for every moment that I could
remember in my life is gone and I am
just free to to realize that I love and
wish nothing but happiness
to the person who I'm sitting with yeah
and so there was just this kind of me
love is that I I think love for that
MDMA experience love is really the the
main epiphany it just just that there's
love is a a state of being which entails
just being deeply committed to the
happiness of other beings whether you
know them or not I mean the epiphany
that really anchored it for me where I
realized that that something unusual had
happened to my mind is so I'm sitting
with you again at the time one of my
best friends and realizing how much I
love this guy and we're both teenage you
know heterosexual men who hadn't really
thought in terms of loving our male
friends the endpoint and I don't think
I'd ever hugged a male friend at that
point in my life right or at least I
don't recall having done that so it was
I might just this outpouring of love for
for a friend of mine and then I realized
that if a stranger had walked into the
room I would have felt the same thing
for the stranger just the difference
would have been so that my love for my
best friend was not predicated on our
history it was he hadn't earned it in
any way and he need not earn it and no
one need earn it right maybe what it was
was it was the nature of my mind and the
summation of my intentions toward every
conscious creature that can suffer or or
or be made happy right so I was just it
just became this this just absolutely
overflowing intention to benefit of
other people and it was very end so you
know the Buddhists have that part right
I mean it was the unity their emphasis
on compassion and and wishing well to
others I mean that that was very much
targeted by that experience yeah
now that doesn't subside I think there
are even more important insights to be
had in meditation and there are other
forms of meditation where you're not
you're not reliably hitting that
experience you know that's not the you
know that's not enlightenment
surely in to put it in a explicitly
Eastern context but it proved to me that
it was possible to have a radically
different experience than I was tending
to have and that you know that that and
it also was kind of obvious that taking
drugs over and over again was not the
way to actualize that experience it just
raised so but that's what got me into
interested in esoteric things like
meditation and sitting silent retreats
yeah and all that so if I'm not mistaken
you open the book up with that story
about your friend right and then that's
sort of so what you're describing is
that feeling of love and sort of
selflessness and wanting this experience
for everybody else then you basically
lay out in the book some of the
practices that you've tried over the
course of your life to kind of get there
but I get what you're saying you're not
saying you're trying to get to that
explicitly to that feeling of love but
either to a oneness what I kept thinking
throughout the book was that really what
you were just trying to do was just shut
off the conscious part of your brain
that that ultimately and I guess this is
what Buddhists probably are ultimately
going for that really if we could just
because you keep referring back to the
inner voice and you that great picture
that you show you know with the the
there's a picture in there the area yeah
our smocks self-portrait the
self-portrait right that were never we
never fully or it's incredibly difficult
to actually let go of that conscious
piece of ourselves but well I think you
means self conscious is it the self
conscious piece right right and that and
I tried desperately on a beach and I had
you know you know and you keep saying
how when you try to do it that often
makes it harder right because you try to
shut off your brain and then your brain
wants to fire off some thoughts and you
can't really control them but I was on a
beach looking at something like that
night I once in a bit you know maybe at
eight days I had a glimmer of it but
this is what people often live their
whole lives to find right yeah yeah and
it can it can be hard to do I may be
meditation really is a training where
it's it's like anything else that you
you start you learn the basic principle
of what to do and initially you're not
very good at it and is
is a lot to a lot to learn not in terms
of information but there's just as a
procedure it's like you're deeply
conditioned not to be able to do this
well you're conditioned to be just lost
and thought and to not know you're
thinking and that's what this feeling of
being a self really and they're really
the freewill is the other side of the
same coin if the feeling of that you
have free will is the feeling that we
call I is the feeling of being a self or
an ego that is riding around in
consciousness or riding around in your
head and authoring your actions and that
it may can take some work but that can
be disconfirmed through meditation which
is really just a process of looking for
that thing you think you are and failing
to find it ultimately in a way that's
conclusive you can fail there ways you
can fail to find it in a way that is you
can't find it because it's not there
right so it's not like you're going to
no one's ever looked inside and found
their ego or found their self or found
the thinker of their thoughts right but
you can look in a way that is
inconclusive right where you feel like
well I just you know of course I guess
like I my eyes can't see my eyes well of
course my self can't see itself right so
you can be convinced that there's just
it's a fruitless effort but it's not
actually fruitless and training and
meditation is a really the only way I
know to reliably run this experiment for
yourself I mean psychedelics can can
override your you know various processes
depending on on the drug we're talking
about in different ways so that you can
you can feel that you're you're free of
self into a significant degree and in
addition feel many other things besides
that there can be very positive but
there's something haphazard to take I'm
I can't give you a pill and say you're
going to experience here is it is the
center of the bullseye that's you know
it's it's very much at the whim of you
know the circumstance and and your brain
and
and thousands of variables we can't
control
so people have you know the best day
their life or the worst on something
like LSD and you can be the same person
more or less in the same situation on
Tuesday it's going to be the best and on
the on a Wednesday it's going to be the
worst and you can't really control it
and that a meditation isn't quite like
that but actually to tie this back
perhaps surprisingly to some of the
other stuff we were talking about so the
experience I just described on MDMA one
of the formative experiences of my life
it just just and it's a state of
consciousness which I am absolutely sure
that if you could dial it in for for all
of humanity you know all of humanity
would find that would be just very close
to the center of the bullseye of what
they want out of life like that's how
you want to feel right especially with
other human beings and there are many
variants of this feeling but just
there's a there's a to speak broadly
about it there's a there's a kind of
experience of self transcendence like
there's that there's a there's a just
imagine a few dials in your in your mind
that you can turn and there's like a
feeling of meaningfulness style you
could crank that up like this is just
profoundly meaningful this experience is
happening right now you know our
sacredness style like this is sacred
everything is sacred I mean this is just
like everything is just perfect exactly
as it is I mean this is kind of the
thrill of just conscious being in the
present it can't get any better right
and now there's other people in it with
you and all you feel is is just you feel
a drop in a way of all the masks you've
built up over your life and all the
paranoia and all you feel would that
person is just just a positive common
project right of solidarity now again
the you know modulo a few changes that
kind of experience can be had in
contexts that are
found ly pathological right it can be
framed by ideas that are world
destroying ideas so I mean the people
who think that all of you all the guys
fighting with Isis are unhappy and just
can't see what they're going to do with
their lives and so they throw their
lives away in the desert of Syria and
they're not you know no no they are
having an experience far closer to what
I'm describing in terms of
meaningfulness and connection and joy
and profundity right and I had this just
know no question that yeah yes I'm sure
there's a few mentally ill suicide
bombers but for the most part you're
talking about truly devout people who
have had their who are focused right who
had their who seen the pointlessness of
materialism and all the other other
entanglements in life they stepped away
from trivial commitments in a way that
is deeply clarifying and it's way that I
understand from in a totally different
context going to sit on meditation
retreats for you know months at a time
in silence I mean so it that that is to
disavow every other project you could be
doing right it's an extreme thing to do
right and I found extreme joy in doing
it but it's you know there's a version
of that that has you strapping on an
ak-47 and going to kill the Jews right
because because of the influence of
specific ideas and it's because of the
framing and this is this is why ecstasy
not the drug but the experience isn't
good enough accident the experience of
ecstasy is ethically neutral right you
can be an ecstatic sadistic dangerous
madman right me and yet yet if we could
just sample your emotional tone at that
moment it's great right right it could
really end of the guy on literally on
ecstasy at the dance called out of the
time his life it could be yeah but I'm a
famous suicide bomber before he
detonates you know I think rather often
feeling great right is not the morbidly
depressed but it's just sure that that
the next moment he's going to open his
eyes in paradise yeah right and there's
no question he's doing the right thing
and you know the reports of ecstatic
smiles on the faces of these people
before they detonate are now fairly
fairly common so it's some that what we
have to and I blogged about this a
little bit of wrote a blog post things
entitled Islam and the misuses of
ecstasy which is which just was my very
brief attempt to get at some of this but
this phenomenon is not yes there there
are political aspects to this and there
are ordinary terrestrial grievances that
some people have and and that potentiate
jihadism and Islamism and all that but
at its core you have real spiritual
yearning from people and a real
disillusionment with the ordinary aims
of an ordinary human life and a true
belief that in the creator of the
universe has given us a guidebook to how
to be ecstatically happy right and part
of it entails not letting your wives or
daughters out of the house right and
covering them up so as not to
destabilize your precarious well-being
with current you know ideation you know
the why don't why do the Taliban not
want to see naked women all over the
place where even in the woman's ankle
because it's not conducive to the purity
of vision right this is very much like a
monk just decided to shave his head and
be a monk right at a Buddhist tradition
right you know Buddhist monks don't want
to hang out with gorgeous women either
because they're they don't want to be
enticed into that video and then they
have I mean the Buddhist strategy to
counteract that is to meditate on the
repulsiveness of the human bodies so
they look at a picture of whoever
Giselle and rather than stay stuck with
these surface features over here
a beautiful woman who's encouraging lust
I'm going to actually picture the fact
that she actually has a skeleton in
there and lymph and bile and blood and
on the inside she's just as disgusting
as any other monkey right right that
sounds fun yeah well as though they're
Buddhists Buddhist monks who do this
practice right big as as an antidote to
their stirrings of their lust right so
but these are very similar projects
framed by radically different ideas
leading to very different behavior in
the world yeah that's really interesting
so it's all it's really about framing it
reminds me a little bit of you know
right after 9/11 when Bill Maher said
you know you can say what you want about
these hijackers but they weren't cowards
because in their minds they were going
for the 72 virgins and prop Barry
possibly had smiles on their faces and
we're doing what they believed to be
true in that moment so it's a it's a
dangerous thing but speaking of a
dangerous thing let's wrap up on your
newest venture huh do people know what
your new books about already or my Megan
oh I'm not sure even sure you know or I
know you know what you're going yeah
I've got a few few irons in the fire so
I'm oh alright well I won't I don't know
what your next book is well let's talk
about artificial intelligence program
how about that was that scary those yeah
that what that works and so I'm I
threatened at one point to be writing a
book about it
hey I think it may be an audio book that
I'm collaborating on with another person
but I just gave a TED talk on on AI
which is you may be up by the time this
video is up but you know if not in the
coming months yeah so I have been
thinking about AI but it's probably not
the topic of my next written book okay
well I possibly just made that up I
don't control my own thoughts that's the
problem right no um so I love look I
love science fiction movies ever since I
was a kid I love dystopian future stuff
I read all philip k dick I love Total
Recall and Minority Report and you know
I Robot and all of this ask them of
stuff and all that I love all of it
so I guess my my first question you on
the AAI front would be I'll go with I'll
go with the biggest question really
which is that if we get to a certain
point with
i artificial intelligence and robots
become aware and all of that stuff this
can only end horribly right is that
pretty much the only it will be good for
a while and then at some point by their
own self-preservation basically they
will have to turn on their masters I
want the answer right now yeah I worry
about it to that degree but not quite in
those terms this I because the concern
for me is not that we will build super
intelligent AI or super intelligent
robots which initially seemed to work
really well and then they will by some
process we don't understand become
malevolent and kill us so the you know
the Terminator movies right that's not
the concern I don't think that's mo most
people who are really worried about this
that's not really what they're worried
about although that's not it's not
inconceivable that's the the it's almost
worse than that what's more reasonable
is that we will will be building as we
are now we're building machines that
embody intelligence to a increasing
degree and it's but it's narrow AI it's
not is the best chess player on earth is
a computer but it can't play tic-tac-toe
right so it's just it's narrowly focused
on a specific kind of goal and that's
broadening more and more we're getting
machines they can play many different
types of games for instance well and so
we're creeping up on what is now called
general intelligence and ability to
think flexibly in in multiple domains
and where you're you're learning and one
domain doesn't cancel you're learning in
another and so so something that's more
like how human beings can acquire many
different skills and and engage many
different modes of cognition and not
have everything fall apart that's the
best the holy grail of artificial
intelligence we want we want general
intelligence and something that's
bust is not brittle it's not it's it's
something that that you know if parts of
it fail it doesn't it's not catastrophic
to the whole enterprise so and I think
there's no question we will get there
but there there's many false assumptions
about the path ahead one is that we're
have what we have now is not nearly as
powerful as a human mind and we're just
going to incremental II get to something
that is essentially a human equivalent
right now I don't see that as the path
for at all I see all of our narrow
intelligence is by much of our narrow
intelligence insofar as we find it
interesting is already super human right
so like we have you know your calculator
on your phone is superhuman for for
arithmetic right and the chess-playing
computer is superhuman it's not it's not
almost as good as a human it's better
than any human on earth and will always
be better than any human on earth right
and more and more we will get that
piecemeal effort of superhuman narrow
AIS and when this has ever brought
together in a general intelligence
you're what you're going to have is not
just another ordinary human level
intelligence there you you're going to
have something that in some ways may be
radically foreign you know it's not
going to be everything about us emulated
in this system but whatever is
intelligent there is going to be
superhuman Oh almost by definition and
if it isn't at you know T equals zero
it's going to be you know the next day
is it because this is it's just going to
improve so quickly and when you talk
about a system that can improve itself
if we ever build intelligent AI that
then becomes the best source of its own
improvement so something they can
improve its source code better than any
human could improve its source code once
we start that process running and the
temptation to do that I think will be
huge then we have what is what has been
worried about for now
seventy-five years that the prospect of
an intelligence explosion was it with
the birth of this intelligence could get
away from us it's now but it's now
improving itself in a way that's
unconstrained right so people talk about
the singularity now which is what what
happens you know when that takes off it
is so it's a horizon line in in
technological innovation that we can't
see beyond and we can't predict beyond
because it's it's now just escaping
you're getting your thousands of years
of progress in minutes right if in fact
this this process gets initiated and so
it's not that we have like superhuman
robots that are just well-behaved and it
goes on for four decades and then all of
a sudden they get quirky and and they
take their interest to heart more than
they take ours to heart and and you know
the game is over right I think what
what's more likely is that we will build
intelligent systems that are so much
more competent than we are that that
note that even the tiniest misalignment
between their goals and our own will
ultimately become completely hostile to
our well-being our survival so that's
that's scarier pretty much yeah then
what I laid out right guy laid out sort
of a futuristic I they're going to turn
on us and start shooting this one day
maybe because of an error or something
but you're laying out really that they
would almost at some point they would if
they could become aware enough they just
simply wouldn't need us because they
would be super humans in effect and that
what use would we serve for them at some
point yeah and I would put aware maybe
not in such a conscious right yeah I
would put consciousness or awareness
aside because it might be that
consciousness comes along for the ride I
mean this may be in fact be the case
that you can't be as intelligent as a
human not be conscious yeah but I don't
know that that's horizon mind stuff
right like well I just don't know that's
actually true it's quite possible that
we could build something that is as
intelligent as we are right in the sense
that it can meet any kind of cognitive
or perceptual challenge or logical
challenge we would pose it know better
than we
can but there's nothing that is like to
be that thing as the lights aren't on
it's not doesn't experience happiness
though it might say it experiences
happiness right I think what will happen
is we will will definitely do you know
the notion of a Turing test you know
this is like if you type and then it
seems like it's responding to you not
actually really what like the Alan
Turing the the person who's more
responsible than anyone else for giving
us computers once thought about what it
would mean to have intelligent machines
and we and he he proposed what has come
to be known the Turing test oh it's like
the chat right yes like when you can't
tell the difference but when you can't
tell whether you're interacting with a
person or a computer that computer in
that case it is passing the Turing test
and this is as a measure of intelligence
that's a certainly good proxy for a more
detailed analysis of what it would mean
to have machine intelligence if I can't
if I'm talking to to to something at
length about anything that I want and I
can't tell it's not a person and it
turns out it's somebody's laptop that
that laptop is passing the Turing test
right it may be that you can pass the
Turing test without even the subtlest
glimmer of consciousness arising in you
right so that that laptop is no more
conscious than that glass of water is
right that may in fact be the case it
may not be though so I'm just that I
don't know there but if if that's the
case that's for me that's the scariest
possibility because what's happening is
so mad I never even heard at least one
computer scientist say this and it was
kind of alarming but I don't really have
a deep argument against it which is if
you assume that consciousness comes
along for the ride if you assume that
anything more intelligent than us that
we give rise to either intentionally or
by by happenstance is more conscious
than we are experience as a greater
range of creative states and well-being
and can suffer more and say it's by
definition in my view ethically it
becomes more
important right I mean it's just if
we're more important than then cocker
spaniels or ants or anything below us in
it then if we create something that's
obviously above us in every conceivable
way and it's conscious right
you can view us just the same way we
view everything as Beneatha yeah it's
more important than us yeah and I would
have to grant that even though I might
not be happy about it deciding to
annihilate us not it it's it's a I don't
have a deep ethical argument against why
I can't say that fee from the you know a
God's eye view it is bad that we gave
birth to super beans that then trampled
on us but then went on to be super in
all the ways we couldn't possibly
imagine just as you know bacteria I
can't imagine what we're up to
right right so there there some computer
scientists who sort of solve the fears
or silence the fears with this idea
which is listen if we build something
that is godlike in that respect we will
have given birth rmer our descendants
will not be more Papes they will be gods
and this is a good thing this is the
most beautiful thing what could be more
beautiful than us creating the next
generation of conscious intelligent
systems that are infinitely profound and
wise and knowledgeable from our point of
view and just improving themselves
endlessly with up to up to the limit of
the resources available in the galaxy
right what could be more rewarding than
that well it's pretty good you know and
the fact that they we all just destroy
ourselves in the process but because you
know we were you know the bugs that hit
their windshield when they were driving
off that's just that the price you pay
well okay that's possible but it's also
conceivable that all of that could
happen without consciousness right that
we could build mere mechanism that is
competent in all the ways so as to you
know just plow us under yeah but that
there is no huge benefit on the side of
of deep experience and well being and
and and beauty and all that is just
blind mechanism which is intelligent
mechanism it is just in the same way
that the best chess playing program is
highly intelligent with respect to chess
but nobody thinks it's conscious so
that's that's the fear that there's an
up but on the way there there'll be many
weird moments where I think we will we
will build machines that pass the Turing
test which is to say they will seem
conscious to us they will seem they will
detect our emotions they'll respond to
our emotions you know your phone will
say you know what you look tired you
know maybe you should take a nap and and
it'll be it'll be right you know I mean
it'll be a better judge of your emotions
than then your friends are right and yet
and at a certain point certainly if you
emulate this in a system whether it's an
avatar online or actual robot that has a
phase right they can make its it can
display its own emotion and we get out
of the uncanny valley where that just
looks creepy and it begins to look
actually you know beautiful and and and
rewarding and and natural then our
intuitions that we're in dialogue with a
conscious other will be played upon
perfectly right and we will I think we
will lose sight of it as being an
interesting problem we will no long it
will no longer be interesting to wonder
whether or not our computers and our
robots are conscious because they will
be they will be demonstrating it as much
as any person has ever demonstrated and
in fact even more right and yet unless
we understand exactly how consciousness
emerges in physical systems at some
point along the way of developing that
technology I don't think we'll actually
know that they're conscious and that's
that will be that will be interesting
because I will successfully fool
ourselves into just assuming it'll it'll
seem totally unethical you to kill your
robot or it off it'll be a murder you
know it'll be a murder that's worse than
your killing a person because at a
certain point it will be the most
competent person you know the wisest
person
Sam I don't know if you're writing a
book about this but you clearly should
write a talk about this to you I'll
write one of the intro sirs out that
there you go so someday yeah
well listen we did two hours here so I'm
not going to give you the full Rogan
treatment but you know yeah half Rogan
we did we did a half Rogan but you know
you you helped me launch the show the
first season in your launch in the
second season and you legally you have
to now launch every season you're
alright with that once a year I'm good
for it and each time I have to increase
it by an hour so in like thirty years is
gonna be old and and breathless yeah
this will be weird but you know it's
always a pleasure talking to you and
I've thoroughly enjoyed this I hope we
moved some some things around in the end
I think we opened up our doors there
hovered more than more than the infamy
so that was that was good there you go
all right well I'm pretty sure you guys
know if you're watching this you know
where to find Sam but it's Sam Harris
org on Twitter and Sam Harris dot org
can I send him anywhere else no that's
good that's the only other thing I would
say is that I am well yeah they probably
know about my podcast but I usually talk
about these things more on my podcast
now than then on my blog by the gothy
the podcast is competed with the blog
enough that now I say it rather than
write it so yeah that's the future
speaking instead of writing there you go
alright thanks for watching guys and
this is just the beginning of the fan
funded show I thank you all who jumped
in and I thank you if you didn't jump in
and you're watching and any of that good
stuff so thank you and we'll do it again
next week